after the second world war in europe
came to a close germany was divided into
occupation zones which soon became east
and west germany the allies had divided
their defeated enemy after a series of
conferences and they decided on this
however there were many different ideas
put forward on how germany would be
split up if at all so how did they come
to this decision why did the allies
choose to divide germany up like this
and not say like this or this well the
first series discussions by the allies
on how to divide germany were at the
tehran conference in late 1943 at this
meeting churchill took the lead he
publicly declared that he wanted the
restoration of austria-hungary based on
these borders and its annexation of
bavaria roosevelt at this time wasn't
100 sold on carving germany up whereas
stalin said no because one he was in
control of hungary at this point and he
wasn't about to hand it over and two he
felt that giving it bavaria would just
give a future germany a grievance as
such by the end of the conference the
allies had sort of maybe agreed to carve
up germany potentially but none of them
knew exactly how in february 1945 as
germany was well on its way to losing
the allies met once again in yota and
this meeting was to determine how
germany would be divided at this point
the british had somewhat called off on
the whole division thing because that
would mean occupation which would cost
money which britain did not have whereas
the soviets would accept dividing
germany so long as they got some of it
and the americans were now very
pro-dismemberment again there was no
agreement on the specifics but the
allies did agree to set up a joint
committee on carving up germany whose
first act was to exclude france the
committee never really did anything
though because everybody had their own
ideas especially stalin who had changed
his mind and just stated publicly that
he would oppose a divided germany the
british and the americans though had
been working together for a plan on how
to divide germany and u.s secretary of
the treasury henry morgenthau had come
up with a detailed plan on how to do
just that under his plan france would be
given this territory denmark this and
poland would get these lands this chunk
in the west would become an
international zone run by the new united
nations and would become
de-industrialized and the rest of
germany would be split into two new
sovereign states north germany and south
germany this plan was very unpopular
except with roosevelt approved churchill
was reluctant to ascend but when
roosevelt offered britain a bunch of
money he changed his mind everyone else
though thought it was terrible and as
such the plans were quickly dropped and
everybody ignored the problem until
germany surrendered at this point
germany was occupied by the allies and
both the ussr and the western allies
wanted to make sure their zones of
occupation were more sensible as such
american troops withdrew to here and
these occupation zones were formally
established that said neither side saw
these as how germany would be split into
new territories stalin openly opposed
any dissolution of germany because he
was confident that with the communist
party established in the east
maintaining a unified state would make
it easier to spread into the west as
tensions between both sides rose in the
cold war began in earnest neither side
wanted to do anything to damage their
own interests this meant that the allies
abandoned east germany to the soviet
sphere and began to merge their own
zones to form west germany and this was
completed in 1949 none of this had been
planned but given that both sides
weren't so sure about how long peace
would last between them an ad hoc
solution was all they had which is why
in the end germany was divided into east
and west and not any other way i hope
you enjoyed this episode and a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly money maker sky chappelle caution
wolf jerry lamdin jordan longley adam
stalter marcus asner wyan hockey spencer
lightfoot rod d martin words about books
podcast captain cydog gustav swan marvin
castle common yoon winston k wood gilly
wiggly daniel to be in miss izzette
matthew shipley aaron the white corey
turner the mcwhopper alex schwinn
anthony beckett coppertone maggie
patzkowski schuenin spinning three
plates and charles the first